Hello everybody welcome back to our
farming simul 25 tips and tricks video
today we're going to talk about all
things goats goats are a new animal to
the Farming Simulator franchise with
respect to Farming Simulator 25 but they
are extremely similar to sheep so if you
have played Farm Sim in the past and you
have kept sheep well goats are going to
fall pretty much under the same general
requirements as sheep had
previously to that end if you take a
look at the animal menu with respect to
the animal pins you're going to find
that sheep and goats are going to share
the same buildings so if we come in here
to build mode we come down to animals
and we toggle over to sheep these are
going to be able to support our goats as
well we have four different base game
buildings we're talking about here an
open sheep pasture that's going to hold
19 sheep or goats by default and it is
also going to require us to deliver not
only food but also water now the rest of
these buildings they are going to supply
water themselves we have one for $48,000
this going to hold 26 sheep or goats
$51,000 and it's going to hold 26 sheep
or goats just a different style of
building and then the larger pin which
is going to hold 68 sheep or
goats something new to farming simil 25
is also the introduction of what they
call dynamic pastur
Dynamic pastures allows us to
reconfigure the shape and capacity of
our animal pins as we place them down so
let's demonstrate how this works with
this large sheet pin that in its base
configuration is set for 68 sheep or
goats we're going to place it down right
here and we're going get a prompt do we
want to customize the fence for our
sheep Barn large yes we do and now you
can see we have the build down but no
fence because now we have the ability to
place our fence so what we're going to
do is well we're just going to build out
a big rectangle why
not and we're going to bring it back to
our pasture you'll see that it's just
going to snap into
place and then it says do you want to
plant Meadow grass for your sheep Barn
yes sure and there we go now we have our
sheep Barn down we have a very large
pasture planned out and if we come over
to this
building we're going to see by coming to
the Paul icon this is going to be where
we can load or unload our animals we now
have the capacity of 113 sheep or
goats now this is a really neat feature
and while in this demonstration I just
simply made a giant rectangle
you could conform this to the land and
or landscaping around your farm so you
can make your way around trees you can
make your way around field edges
roadsides whatever you want you can do
this up on hillsides it's really going
to add a whole lot of customization to
the
game the next thing we need to talk
about is how do you get your animals
well there's two real ways to get your
animals you can either buy them directly
here at the pin or you can go down to
the animal dealer and buy them from
there and transport them to your farm if
you buy them directly from the animal
pin since we are talking about goats
today we're going to scroll all the way
down to the bottom and we can buy goats
in either one of three different ages we
can buy newborn goats at an age of zero
months for $200 a goat if we were to do
that we would double click on this we
would scroll up to a particular number
that we wanted to do and you can see how
much money it's going to cost us with a
small delivery
fee let's go ahead and buy those
in now we can select 3mon age juvenile
goats and they are going to be a little
bit more costly at $38 a piece we can do
the same thing we can click here once
this is selected we can either tick up
or if we wanted to fill the whole thing
we could just tick down and that's going
to show us the available capacity I
would C though not to fill up the Sheep
pen because you won't have room for them
to reproduce when the time comes so
let's go ahead and buy these
in and then we have our oldest goats our
mature goats at an age of 16 months
they're going to be the most costly
because they're going to start producing
goat milk in large quantities right
away we can buy those for
$777 and again we're going to buy just
now let's talk about our goats goat ages
reproductive cycle Etc so our 16-month
old goats they're going to be our adult
goats you see they have a age of 16
months as I mentioned goats also have a
puberty period of 16
months so once a goat reaches 16 months
it's going to be able to start to
reproduce and there is a gestation
period of 5 months which means at this
point forward these 16-month-old goats
as they continue to
age will reproduce one for one every
five months so 5 months from now we will
have
20 or we have another 10 Z Monon old
goats those zero month old goats now
will be 5 months old and the three-month
old goats will be 8 months old 5 months
after that we'll have another newborn
set of goats 10 because well our
16-month old goats will have produced
again and the cycle will just continue
when our 3month old goats reach the age
of 16 months well they will start
reproducing as well and then our zero
month old goats again once they reach 16
months they will start reproducing also
visually we have three different
well models of goats we have our newborn
goats we have our juvenile goats
and we have our adult
goats so here we go
newborns
juveniles
and our
adults as the goats age their visual
representation will of course change our
newborn goats will change to be the same
visual appearance as juveniles when they
reach an age of 3 months our juveniles
will stay that appearance until they
reach the adult age of 16 months at
which time then they will visually
change their
appearance let's jump over to the animal
dealer now and talk about what it would
take to purchase animals there and
deliver them to the
farm over at the animal dealer which on
riverin Springs is going to be located
right here right across the street from
the shop and our starting Farm is
located right here of course depending
on the map you're on the location of the
animal dealer will vary one thing that
won't be though is that Kate will be
here ready to answer any questions that
you might have but really we don't have
any questions for
her we're going to come over here to our
animal trigger and we're going to make
use of the flegal ttw 140 animal
trailer let's take a look in our vehicle
shop we're going to scroll down to
animals and in the animals section
there's going to be an animal transport
for transporting our goats we're going
to either need the Noah ttw 140 or the
Wilson Silver Star Trailer Silver Star
will either require a semi or a fifth
wheel Dolly meanwhile the no will
connect either to a truck or
tractor once we are positioned inside
the trigger we're going to be able to go
into our tractor we can hit R and R will
now allow us to either load onto or if
we tackle this switch to load off of the
trailer since we don't have any on the
trailer we can't offload right now we're
going to toggle over to our sheeps and
goats we're scroll down to the bottom
list and you can see once again these
prices are the same as they were at the
farm but in this case we do not have a
delivery fee we can store a total of 13
goats into this trailer so let's go
ahead and buy just 10 $7,777 zero
delivery fee because we are bringing our
own
trailer and we now have purchased those
and you can see that they are in the
trailer just like we can buy animals
here at the animal dealer we can also
sell them back so if we have had
reproduction to the point where now we
are over full we are at our capacity on
our pastures let's pull that
up right we are reached Max Capacity on
our pin we just cannot at any point in
time hold more therefore when our goats
reproduce we're losing we're losing
goats right when it fills up our goats
will reproduce they just won't spawn
anywhere yeah tell me about it it's kind
of interesting any rate
what we need to do is we need to thin
out the herd there's a couple ways to do
that we can either put down another
pasture and move our goats from one
pasture to another using our trailer or
we can load goats onto the trailer bring
them down to the animal dealer and sell
them back to to sell them back we're
going to come here to our menu like we
did to load onto but we're going to
toggle this switch which is then going
to say we want to sell
from now do note we're not going to get
nearly the price that we
sold for our animals as we paid for them
but with respect to reproduction those
were basically free animals
anyway so getting a little bit of money
is going to be
helpful now with respect to what do our
goats eat well let's hit escape and
let's jump back here to our animal menu
and we can see from this information
screen that our sheep are going to
either take Meadow grass or grass or hay
so Meadow grass would be the grass that
is growing
within the pin and hay or grass would be
in the format of either Bales or loose
material brought to the pasture so we
have three different types of bales that
I've got here just to visually
demonstrate we have small baby Bales I
call them small square
bales then we have the larger square
bales these come in three different
sizes of which this is the medium size I
believe and then we have round bales and
again this is the medium size they come
in three different sizes I have here
bales of hay but you can also bail
straight
grass and typically to feed
your goats you're going to be presenting
the bail to the feed
trough and the bail is just going to
basically be consumed within the feed
trough and it's going to
vanish you're going to be transporting
your Bales typically with a front loader
you can either use a front loader like
this a self-propelled variety or you can
get front loader arms for your tractor
and make use of it that way we're going
to find these here under loaders so we
have our front
loader we have front loader arms that we
would attach to our tractor we have then
front L tools like a pallet fork and
bail Spike we could also use a tandler
or a skid steer if we wish to and then
also they're going to have the
corresponding pallet fork and bail
Spike for each of their Associated
Vehicles so here we have the bail Spike
here we have the pallet fork and we're
going to need the pallet Fork because
our goats are going to spawn pallets of
milk we going need a flatbed truck or
trailer of some sort in order to
transport our milk and possibly our
bales from the field to the farm so here
I have the international CV series and
we could take these sides down load up
our pallets of milk on this because
we're going to either transport our milk
to either the base game Dairy that is
either pre-placed on the map or one of
these two placeables which we'll talk
about in a little
bit for the open sheep pasture I
mentioned that they require water so if
you have placed that down you're going
to need to have a water tanker you're
going to find the water tanker under
Vehicles once again down here under the
animal section we have barrels and we
have four different trailers that are
going to be able to transport your water
I have the 1600 version right
here and then for loose
material well I want to jump up on here
come on
for loose material you'll need some sort
of trailer
or forage Wagon in order to transport
your loose grass or hay we have here the
farm Tech fdk 650 and it is loaded up
with a load of
hay because there's two of different
ways to feed you can either feed as I
mentioned in bail or loose format now
there is currently as a version
1.2.1 of the game an interesting bug
with this building here on the right it
does not appear to accept
Bales meanwhile the other pastures do so
the only way to feed this particular
building is going to be with loose
material again as of version
1.2.1 if you're watching this video and
the game has been subsequently updated
then this issue may be
corrected you can see once we add our
pay in here if we look inside our
building this hates you can see that we
have hay now in that trough
inside in addition to hey I mentioned
that our animals are going to be able to
feed from the meadow grass that is
within the
pin typically meadowgrass is going to
take a little bit of time to register
from the time that you have placed it
down so what I'm going to do is come
over here and go ahead and fast forward
into September and we should see now
Meadow grass appear on our food
charts good morning everybody it is now
September and if we check our animal
screen what we can now see that we have
Meadow grass appearing for all of our
pins we have a health of 60% don't worry
about that it is slightly affected
because of September we didn't feed this
particular building but we're going to
see in other screens that we have 100%
but any rate we have Meadow grass and we
have a capacity this is that big pen
that we put down
1983 L and our sheep within this are
going to be consuming Meadow grass until
winter at which time the grass will die
back and we'll need to then basically
make sure we are definitely feeding hay
to all of our animals otherwise their
health and their productivity will
suffer we toggle over to our next pin
well here we have our large pin that had
17 no 10 adult sheep they are now 17
months old because one month has passed
they had grass or hay already supplied
for them so they have 100% health so if
you want to maximize your animals
productivity feed them right away don't
just count on the meadow grass being
there for them we can also see that we
are 20% into our reproductive cycle as
we move every month this is going to
jump 20% because it's 5 months until we
reach 100% and at that point in time
we're going to see 10 newborns also
appear in this building and then our
reproductive will go back to
0% the Sheep Barn are newborns are now
one month of age they are 6% through
their puberty cycle remember they have
to reach an age of 16 months before they
ready to reproduce and we once again we
have our metal grass showing up we have
our grass showing up and a total
productivity and health of
100% we can see this continue now these
goats they didn't again have any grass
fed to them so their productivity and
their health is down they're not
reproducing at all because well their
health isn't maximized out so again in
order to maximize your
productivity go ahead and have on hand
some hay to feed these guys when you
first put them
down then we have our sheep pasture or
open sheep pasture we still are good
with our water capacity we fed them a
little bit of grass from that small
baale and our Meadow grass so they are
doing fine as
well now back to the shop because I
mentioned you want to make sure that you
can feed these animals from the outset
and if you don't have hay right away
well you can come here to the shop and
you can actually buy it in which is
pretty neat so to do that we're going to
come down here to objects category Bales
and we can buy square bales of hay round
bales of hay and you can pretty much
just decide which bail do you want to
buy how many Bales do you want to buy
with a total of up to eight and if we
buy these they're going to spawn over
the shop we'll need to come and then
transport those back to the farm
now that some time has passed we also
can talk a little bit about what do
these guys produce well they produce
goat milk and goat milk is going to
appear on pallets of these milk jugs and
when the pallet reaches 1,000 L it will
be full and another pallet will spawn
until it's 1,000 L the capacity of this
pallet will just keep increasing right
now we have 164 L of goat milk in in
this pasture in our larger pasture where
we placed 10 of each size
goat we also have our
milk but you're going to notice it has
just 24 L of milk well the reason for
that is remember we didn't feed these
guys so they went a month without being
able to eat so they've only been able to
eat since September when that meow grass
was registered again it really holds
that we should feed our animals at the
start make sure they maintain them being
well
fed our newborns as should be aren't
producing any
milk but what's interesting is our
juveniles are now in my opinion that's
just a bug and that should be fixed out
juveniles should not be producing milk
we shouldn't get any milk until our
animals are at full age and here we have
another set of animals that are full age
again goat milk is only 20 leaders
because we didn't feed these guys
anything
either so as I mentioned our juveniles
do produce
milk a little bit of milk we have a
whole six lers of milk but we have milk
nonetheless now this also may be patched
in a future game update where juveniles
don't produce
milk when we get our pallet of milk well
what do we do with it well we can sell
our raw goat milk at the dairy if we do
not own the dairy or if we own the dairy
we can produce either bottled goat milk
or we can produce goat cheese so here we
have a bottled goat milk pallet and here
we have a pallet of goat
cheese we have two different placeable
dairies within the base game or we have
depending on the map you might have a
dairy already
pre-placed we do not have a dairy
available as far as a production there
is a dairy available that is a cell
point but it is not a productive point
so that is something to take note of you
may or may not have a production Dairy
on your map if we look at our prices
screen and we come down here to our goat
milk sell our goat milk at the dairy
this is going to be the cell point on
the map
or we could take it to the dairy if we
own the dairy and use it in our
production on this map since we have a
warehouse we could buy milk in but don't
it's it's never going to be profitable
to buy goat milk in in order to run it
through a
production you see our raw goat milk on
easy economy is going to have an average
low price of
7,614 per th000 liter to 9,220 2 per
th000 liter again if you're on normal or
hard economy these prices will be
different our bottled goat milk which is
an output of our production can be
either sold at on riverin Springs
Farmers Market Co crest valley train
sell point the restaurant or the small
farmers kiosk just up by the road and
the average low price is going to be
5,697 meanwhile the average high price
is going to be 6,900 again on easy
economy our goat cheese again based per
thousand lers is going to have an
average low of
4752 or an average high of
5754 and it's going to be available for
sale again at the farmers market train
sell Point restaurant or the small
farmers
kiosk let's take a look at our
production chains that we own we're
going to be able to bring our raw goat
milk to our production chain and we're
going to be able to produce bottled milk
at a ratio of 1 to two so for every 10
units of goat milk we bring we're going
to make 20 units of bottled goat milk so
imagine 1,000 L of goat milk in equals
2,000 L of goat milk out bottled with
respect to the small production we're
going to be able to do that in cycles of
14.4 cycles per month the larger placed
Dairy well it's going to be able to
Output 10 times that at 144 cycles per
month
our goat cheese is going to take three
units of goat cheese for six units of
goat cheese or sorry three units of goat
milk for six units of goat cheese so
again we are doubling and we're going to
do that at 960 cycles per month for goat
cheese at the big Dairy meanwhile it's
going to be just 96 cycles per month at
the small Dairy so in all regards the
small Dairy is going to produce at
1/10th the speed of the large
Dairy so hold on this is me post
production coming to you while I'm
editing this video I noticed that we can
also make standard butter with goat milk
that wasn't in the Giants information
with respect to what goats are good for
so with respect to butter we're going to
take three units of goat milk and it's
going to make 10 units of standard
butter that's at our larger Dairy which
is going to be able to do 744 cycles per
month the smaller Dairy is going to be
able to take three units of goat milk
and produce 10 units of butter but it's
going to be only able to process at
74.4 cycles per month and now on with
the rest of our
show so guys that is just about it I
think that wraps up everything you need
to know with respect to goats and how to
car for them here in Farming Simulator
25 where to place the goats the fact
that you can customize your PIN and make
it larger and suit your area as you
should so fit with the use of the new
Dynamic pastures feature how to buy your
goats either here at the farm or at the
animal dealer with a trailer what to
feed your goats and how to feed your
goats either by Veil form or by loose
form and then
basically what goats will produce how
often goats will reproduce and then
where we can take our goat output in
Goat milk and either produce additional
products with it or sell it if it is
available for sale I'd love to know your
all's thoughts down in the comments
below with respect to goats and farming
simulator 25 and until next time happy
farming
hey Walter what's
up for